So my name's Kurt Smith, I'm a data scientist
on the Analytics team here at Twitter. Been here about
two and a half years right now and I
took, you know, a somewhat long and windy path to
getting here. I actually started out in college studying
chemical engineering and then ended up doing a PhD in
computational fluid dynamics and molecular modeling And spent quite a
while working in academia doing computational research I went from
there I moved to San Francisco several years back, and I
initially started working in the chemicals industry doing a lot of
molecular modeling. And from there the first big leap I would,
I may that I would say brought me more to the data
science direction was, moving to a startup in the healthcare space,
that was doing a lot of data analysis on a risk modeling
around chronic disease. And that really was the opportunity, or gave
me the opportunity to take a lot of my mathematical background, and
apply it to data driven problems. After working in
that area for a few years, I started to look
around in other fields with interesting data challenges. And
that brought me to moving to social media and Twitter.